Fox News Alert moments ago Trump
addressing the illegal immigration
crisis facing our country the president
taking aim at Democrats and blaming them
for the laws that enable the problem we
will not allow our generosity to be
abused by those who would break our laws
defy our rules violate our borders break
into our country illegally we won't
allow it
through the laws are so bad they're not
archaic they're incompetent it's not
that they're old they're just bad and we
can't get any Democrat votes to change
them it's only the Republicans that are
in unison they want to change the
hot-button issue in the last couple of
weeks has been the migrant Caravan
headed towards the United States Trump
once again vowing to stop it at this
very moment large well-organized
caravans of migrants are marching toward
our southern border some people call it
an invasion it's like an invasion these
are tough people in many cases a lot of
young men strong men and a lot of men
that maybe we don't want in our country
but again we'll find that out through
the legal process but these illegal
caravans will not be allowed into the
United States and they should turn back
now because they're wasting their time
they should apply to come into our
country we want them to come into our
country the president also saying he'll
crack down on meritless claims for
asylum my administration is finalizing a
plan to end the rampant abuse of our
Asylum system under this plan the
illegal aliens will no longer get a free
pass into our country by lodging
meritless claims in seeking asylum
instead migrants seeking asylum will
have to present themselves lawfully at a
port of entry so they're going to have
to lawfully present themselves at a port
of entry
okay one two issues here because of the
laws in this country they treat the
from Central America different than they
treat people from Canada or Mexico so if
you come with a child and you're from a
Central American country and you cross
the border and if you say you're fleeing
violence they will immediately accept
you into this country and release you
into this country because of the laws do
you think that the system is being gamed
by people who you know there's lawyers
down there they're telling them what to
say right before they cross would you
make any changes to the illegal
immigration problem at all yeah well I
mean if you want to make a change with
regard to the asylum rules I guess
that's up to us as the American people
and we can do that at any time the
Democrats couldn't help with that yeah I
mean it's the Republicans who have
failed in the two years they've been
there with Trump but yes we're right
Democrats are willing to help and I
think they've been willing to help when
we had packages for comprehensive
immigration reform that were defeated by
Republicans in Congress but what we're
seeing here I just find this kind of
like is this bizarre is this Halloween
still I mean the Republicans can't talk
about the economy or taxes apparently so
they start a culture war and demonize
these poor people who are stragglers who
are thousands of miles away from the
border and don't have any weapon oh
we're gonna have our military I mean
Trump is creating a photo opportunity to
spur Republican turnout it is so
transparent and I just got to think our
people that stupid that they are just
gonna fall for this time after time
after time well I don't think the
president was the one that started the
caravan he had a caravan crisis on the
border during the Obama administration
he chose to handle it one way the
president morgan handle it there was a
cry snow saying there's no crisis now
okay I believe there is a crisis do you
believe there's no crisis Morgan no I I
see I think the caravan is is really
it's missing the forest for the trees
when you look at it the caravan to me is
more symbolic of of the immigration
fight and the fact that there's many
Americans when you look at the polling
on this why is the president bringing
this up because if you look at
Republican voters this is at the top of
their list including health care and so
you know I think that people in general
are frustrated that the Republicans have
made no progress on this I mean the
president campaigned on the wall he's
gotten some money for the wall but he
hasn't been able to get everything that
he wants so for me to care
van is just a larger representation of
frustration at our government for not
solving the problem and that's what he's
bringing it up it's a political winner
for him right and the timing a week
before and a big White House speech and
took a few questions damn well the
president didn't start the caravan right
it's not his problem it's not his fault
that the caravan started a month before
the election and there as they marched
closer or even though I know there are
thousands of miles away or a thousand
miles away
like he didn't start that so the visual
is like that was not of his creation he
didn't make this up out of whole cloth
this is actually happening and you can
see it every day there's a picture today
of the four year old girl who was so
exhausted she just refused to go any
farther okay so that's a humanitarian
problem again not his fault and he's
trying to figure out a way to do
something with it he told them go back
but I think that maybe he could go a
step further and I don't think it'll
happen now but he chose the Roosevelt
Room for this speech for a reason he
didn't have a bunch of people behind him
he wasn't at a campaign rally he did it
in the Roosevelt Room where you decide
policy so he's saying that this is a
policy that we have to deal with I think
the speech could've been a little
shorter maybe but this is what he was
saying I also feel like it is clear that
we need an orderly process to figure out
how do you separate economic migrants
from people who are really in need of
asylum my concern about the pushing
asylum seekers honest to goodness people
with integrity that have the need for
asylum to push them to a port of entry
is that they might be so desperate that
they can't get there I think that you
can tell the difference between somebody
who wants to have a better life and the
chance to live in America versus
somebody who is really desperately
fleeing violence from their government
could you migrate to a port of entry or
does it have to might be able to you
might be able to do it I think I think a
lot of this stuff has actually happened
is handled at the embassy level in other
places overseas the last thing I would
say is I feel like we need to do
something that solve the problem at its
source capitalism is the answer and I
think if the president could do
something whoever happens in the
midterms who cares he's president for
the next two years he's running for
re-election what could he do that would
be big and different what about like a
Marshall Plan type thing for a very
neglected part of the world Latin
America Central America South America
do something big and bold to reintroduce
capital something like generational that
would have a lasting impact that would
go along with not just the border
security but trying to bring people
together and say if we want to take care
of this region and protect our own
borders let's do something that will
actually make a difference and it would
be that in US aid administrator mark
green is doing exactly what Dana is
talking about he's trying to reform u.s.
aid which we've been giving to this
Central American countries which by many
definitions meet a failed failed state
status and it's not just the US Mexican
border we're seeing the same thing
happen in the failed state of Venezuela
thousands of migrants a day of people
fleeing Venezuela going to the Colombian
border so we should be looking at this
similar to lead to how we look at failed
States in the Middle East that we've
worked on for so many years looking at
the failed States in Central America
I totally agree with you and I think
mark green at USA it has a great plan
for this all right Greg what do you
think I think that a lot of these
problems are due to how the media
positions these issues number one want
brings up the fact that no one's talking
about the economy that's because the
economy is effin great right now you're
gonna have three and a half to four
percent growth full unemployment wages
are soaring we just found that today but
the media it doesn't like to talk about
planes that land safely they can only
report on planes that crash so good news
about the economy mysteriously is no
news on the other networks we try to
talk about it here but it's often
ignored because it's such good news now
let's talk about immigration he Donald
Trump had to set the whole issue up at
the beginning as a strain on the system
the reason is is that the media believes
you can only hold two positions you can
either say we are a nation of immigrants
or it's a nation under siege but the
fact is human beings hold a portfolio of
positions regarding everything like
immigration you could hold a port in a
bunch of different positions on crime
right you could be I could be for the
death penalty but think the drugs should
be legalized you can have a portfolio of
interests about climate you could
believe that there's climate change but
that the policies are wrong but the
activist media that bans nuance so that
you can like if you have a straw if you
feel for strong immigration you want
people to come here but you want to tie
neptr loopholes that doesn't work for
the media that doesn't compute they need
they need to have you in your own box
and it's so infuriating because I am for
strong immigration I want people to come
here President Trump said he wants
people to come here but in his brain he
knows like everybody who is immersed in
this kind of like law and order criteria
that you keep in your brain that there
has to be a system and that system
enables you to have a portfolio of
beliefs unfortunately the media cannot
handle that because they're stupid well
I just wanted to quickly say that it's
not just the media you look at the ads
and there's little ton of ads right now
and they're going into the weekend and
the ads run by the Republicans are not
talking about the economy Gregg because
it's not gaining traction with the votes
as a purse waste and that's it that's
that's a problem the second thing I
would say is but look at the ad that is
being run the one that the president
retweeted that has like some Mexican guy
who shot a I think it was a law
enforcement officer saying oh I'm coming
back I'm gonna kill more I mean you
think my god this is Willie Horton all
over again when in fact we know from the
numbers that in fact people who are here
illegally have a lower rate of violent
crime than people who are knaves that
was that Willie was it wrong to point
out that Willie Gordon was a furloughed
killer yeah that wrong no no I submit
you why are you on the side of Willie
Horton
no I'm us I'm on the side of not playing
to racial antagonisms in the society
back dry side of necessity private
safety not your sorrow you're seeing
rates when you're seeing race or
nobody's seeing race here you saw
raiding Willie Horton oh no that was a
furloughed killer are you kidding me
that was a furloughed killer
Willie you're seeing race I'm not oh I'm
seeing a furloughed killer